with Android you can easily customize
your homescreen just like you can on a
computer Android allows you to adapt
your handset in many ways tailoring the
look of your homepage is simple by
changing the image for your wallpaper
you can do this with a nifty feature
across apps called long press anytime
you select and hold an item on the
touchscreen you find an additional set
of actions using long press on the home
screen I can select an existing image
from the wallpaper gallery go to the web
to grab an image or choose one from my
picture album
you can also customize the applications
on your home screen
you can select Gmail or other useful
Google Apps or Banzai Blast
even bookmarks for websites or sites you
want easily accessible
what's great is that you can do this
with contacts and Gmail labels you
frequently use as well
Android fits your diverse lifestyle you
can create a work page a play page an
entertainment page or a communication
page making it simple to navigate your
needs as you move throughout the day